on met du tc directement dans le port de
béziers et oui il faut savoir qu'il ya
un port dans béziers au niveau du canal
du midi
bien entendu pas de porc dans l'orb
donc on va voir on peut trouver à mon
avis à mon avis cm se rassemblent pour
ça on va dire mais ça a déjà été fait
mais comme on a une liste désespère pas
[Musique]
on
à castres
ok
aucune tige
metallica
un couteau
laurent
un oeil
une pièce
je
parce que c'est ça elizabeth way
à bas les péniches va plaindre allez
ciao
pierre
je
oh oh oh intéressant pas mal ça un peu
rouillé mais dans l'ensemble ça doit le
faire à garder
olé voilà allait bien mais je garde tout
je garde tous pour la collection
personne n'est allé depuis un moment
ouais mais je pense que c'est lié au
confinement saporta circulent des
péniches ouais enfin c'est pêcheurs de
trésors à l'inversé bonne balade
bah ouais un peu de tout des outils
cuillère alors là
ouais bon étonnant
regardez pas les leurs de pêche on a
fait pas mal de temps
[Musique]
bon bah voilà donc en une heure pas aux
vrais avec le piste sur cette portion
voilà france hors ciseaux inox couteau
inox quelques outils thierry knox
cuillère paradoxe parce que c'est la
bagarre des vraiment les foules
et voilà belpech petit péché léman à
capestang dans l'autre on va voir ce
qu'on peut trop de boer
[Musique]
où
il
[Musique]
oh
pour
[Musique]
oh
c'était peut-être justin je pense à ça
c'est mort même si peut-être sympa la
base super jeunes et aux récepteurs vous
vous montrerez bonne nettoyer un peu
ok c'est de la merde a toujours tiré
parce que c'est malsain j'ai presque ce
machin mais c'est lourd
un défilé ou quoi
[Musique]
allez y
donc on se retrouve avec la clé nettoyer
donc c'est une très belle pièce de clés
en laiton alors pour les années et
quelque chose qui donne une petite idée
c'est la voiture à l'arrière qui semble
être une voiture des années 1930 plus ou
moins donc si vous avez une meilleure
idée du preneur
j'ai cherché sur internet et j'ai trouvé
aucune équivalence donc en laiton comme
ça et avec cette forme là au bout j'ai
vraiment rien trouvé qui correspondait
donc si vous avez des idées ou vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui s'y connaît
dans les clae anciennes je suis preneur
et on se retrouve dans une prochaine
vidéo